number one national best-selling author
of the book retire inspired America's
voice on retirement chris hogan ramsey
personality joins me for a couple of
seconds here answering your questions
about investing and about retirement
science starts off this segment in
odessa texas a scion how are you I'm
good how are you better than I deserve
your question for Chris and I am on
babysat for me and my husband and we're
actually getting to skip today to step
seven because we don't have children
right now and we paid off a house and
maybe step two fantastic so you're on
baby step seven no yes sir and I was
wondering how I know that once that's
been done fifteen ago sinan babysat for
but how many I know on something that's
out your retirement maybe step 7 so how
would I go about that yes ma'am well
first of all congratulations for the
progress you all are making I love the
fact that you guys are on onboard and
aligned I would tell you to do that to
do this have you all done your riq yet
okay now that's the retiring smart
quotient that's on my website it allows
people to plug in some basic data to
understand what's the big number you're
gonna need and so I would encourage you
to go to my website you and your husband
sit down together and plug that in and
begin to talk about what do you want to
do in retirement what's your dream look
like and I'm telling you do that because
once you have an idea of that big number
now what I want you to do is to connect
with one of our endorsed local providers
to really talk about the other options
you have in front of you you know not
only can you max out your 401k or 403b
but you have options outside of those
employee type of accounts to be able to
do some things on your own so what's
your household income
we made 128 last year okay okay you
could do two Roth IRAs well how old are
you I'm 24 and 31 wow that's amazing
alright yeah you do two Roth IRAs at
5500 each and good growth stock mutual
funds with long track records
do you have retirement plans offered at
work either one of you I do and I
actually have a Roth 401k and they offer
a match great max put as much in the
401k as you're allowed to put okay so
them today and they said that that was
eighteen thousand that's correct that's
right that's the most per year you can
put in it has to do with your income
also but the max federally is eighteen
thousand that's right and so if you do
two at your all's age if you do nothing
else but to Roth IRAs plus a Roth 401k
with a match at eighteen thousand and
you don't do and and none of those
numbers ever change you don't know what
you never get a raise that's right are
done of these numbers every change
you're gonna have millions and millions
and millions of dollars so you're gonna
be in really really good shape but
that's what we mean we say max it out
take full advantage of any of the
programs that are available and Sian
when Dave is talking about Roth what
he's talking about is that's after tax
dollars so you've already paid taxes on
it so you're gonna experience growth
tax-free which is a beautiful thing in
this day and age so stay focused and
keep doing the good stuff I'm very proud
of them very at that age they're killing
it's amazing hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind
you